Bloomberg to loose Oh Laura NEPA of
Bloomberg News is in st. Louis and had
an eventful nice to loose good morning
to you what is a single message you have
for our viewers this morning I would
definitely say that things have taken a
very drastic turn for the worst in
Ferguson what started off as a peaceful
protest descended into a pretty nasty
situation with tear gas in the streets
even children were gasping for air with
tear gas in their nostrils in the
streets of Ferguson relief method to
lose within the geography our Ferguson
what will they be the difference between
many police officers and what I assume
will be many more National Guard how
will that change the landscape that you
observed last night it's interesting
because the police already have
military-style assets they have huge
trucks they have long-range rifles so it
will be interesting to see how many
officers come with the National Guard it
seems like the National Guard will bring
more high-powered assets and maybe even
more boots on the ground who try to
quell the violence that we've seen to
lose so we can hear a lot of noise going
on behind you right now is a quiet at
six in the morning five in the morning
local time or is there continued
protests when I left the site i left the
site of about an hour ago after
conference when i left the site it was
pretty quiet the streets work were
pretty clear most of what happened most
of the action actually took place last
night around eight nine ten in the in
the evening police were able to clear
the streets using teargas Tolosa we know
that there are eight or nine people who
have been injured some seriously and you
mentioned that the police actually has
long-range rifles can you tell us how
those people were injured those eight or
nine police did not say how the people
how everyone was was injured they did
say that there were two people who had
gunshot wounds that did not come from
police but came from other people there
are some
what police are calling agitators in the
crowd were using violence to sort of
break up these peaceful protests and
some of them are using violence on one
another and some are targeting the
police though the injuries are mostly
from within within the crowd so those
give us is scheduled for today I mean
it's early in the night you've been up
all night what would you presume will be
the events of this morning and into the
afternoon well the the local school
district has canceled school so it's
likely that there will be even more
children who might take part in more
protest there's going to be the National
Guard rolling in but I think there are a
lot of people who are angry about what
happened last night and who said they're
going to go right back out to the
streets so this is definitely escalating
and it's going to continue